Gaming week say it with me
gaming we Gary we starting up with the
ultimate game of all time minecraft
that's right I have not played Minecraft
properly in ever I play the game when he
was in alpha that's right
hipster notch supporter I think a lot of
us has changed I'm not sure okay let's
just jump into it why do I not have
sound okay so create a new world or
should we name it bro land good one here
we go guys historical moment my first
video ever was a Minecraft video does it
always take this long here it is oh my
god after all these years I'm back in
Minecraft I have this near is that a
[ __ ] horse that's a freaking horse oh
my god there's horses in Minecraft
kawaii me who modest can I write it look
it's tiny horse hello tiny horse this is
amazing I love mine why are they sliding
okay bye bye horse so I have I got my
outfit there it is yeah Bob server God
hey whatever will it be I don't really
remember how you play I think the first
thing you do is chop down wood that's
right
yeah yeah you definitely shut down wood
shop shop shop there we go
new recipe on my amazing
you know I'm sort of a veteran I don't
need you kids to tell me how to play
Minecraft I know how to play Minecraft
oh god what was that sound oh yeah you
have to build it ah you have to build a
shelter before night that means we got
to get fire that means we got to build a
door we got a lot of things to build Oh
God help is there anyone out there oh
that's not what I wanted to do all right
I got a lot of stuff so how do I build a
twig there it is I got it still got it
baby look at this dude
what else can I build oh my god the
crafting table I'm learning so much
about science and stuff I'm already
minecraft pro and I've only play like -
ah Jesus okay what is that why is it so
spooky hi Mike I'll go back to the
horses all right so where should we
build our first house here's nice is by
the beach it's pretty epic yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah here we'll build it here
this is perfect what is that
Nani Cody what is that ha there's
Octopussy is cats all right before we
advance any further I must protect
myself
now I remember some things there it is
still got it so how was the sewer then
so recite where's its recipe okay
sword oh it does it for you let's get an
axe as well oh my god this is so easy
kitty cat hey don't you dare hurt kitty
whatever you are kitty come here what
the hell are you can i murder them wait
let me see
alright nihilus murder to them
he would rather dry and himself than be
with me he just disappeared
I'm a murderer what have I done can I
kill you ah no ah I've already failed
alright now played seriously Felix
goddammit speedrun happening oh god the
summer moments the feelings are all
coming back to me late at night after
party you had a good time but in reality
you just wanted to go home and play
Minecraft and I stayed up all night
digging deep down just to see what was
happening finally a game that gave me a
picture that made me feel goddamnit my
god why this game is so anime how I need
a shovel of course
why is minecraft so anime alright I
think we're ready to just dig down so I
want to have like the mine a little bit
away from the home right so here's ok
this is perfect
we'll just cut here Stone Age that means
you know what kids I can make a stone
goddamn pickaxe boy so now we can dig a
lot faster epic got to have I need coal
don't eh
I need to find coal oh god the Sun is
setting boys Oh God
I need something to light up god damn it
this is real bad Pig please do something
I can't even ride the pig are you
kidding me all right Cole let's find
coal a perfect way out here there should
oh whoa whoa there we find coal let's
just be careful with the lava there it
is there's coal yes we're gonna live
what is this green bar I'm getting the
cold right god dammit how deep does this
go okay we have coal which of course
means we can make a
all right let's be careful here with a
lot can we build the bridge over the
lava I need to cross here hey we're
going and get Diamond boys that's the
goal of this series is it hard to get
diamond I don't even remember okay we're
going deeper I hear something do I have
a sword I do I have a sword and I'm not
afraid to use a goddamn it why do it huh
what was that why can I hear them ah
what what is down there oh my god what
what is happening down there there's a
chest down there yeah there's a chest
down there I gotta get the chest
we just gotta have a plan B all right
what's the plan B then let's go bro
[Music]
ah oh look how cozy they have it over
there
looking good God well I'll get my stuff
back I'll get revenge those skeletons
are gonna freakin pay for what they did
to me and my father pushed and flab and
what is that oh god damn it you're
disgusting
now the skeletons everywhere why is the
Sun that's helping oh look there's so
much stuff ah
all right all right I've had enough I've
had enough I didn't
horses do something oh dude I'm thinking
a hole
I'm digging a hole I'm done with this
you can't hurt me in my hole you can't
hurt me in my hole you can't hurt me and
so the journey begins for Felix Kajal
bug after returning years from Minecraft
to reclaim what was once he is there's a
freaking waterfall all right I'll find
that there's a freaking chicken what up
chicken cool it's awesome so much has
changed so much yes
changed here it is here it is
I'll find them and I'll kill them
those bastards were pay for what they
did to me the humiliated me but this
time I come back and I come back strong
stronger than I ever was stronger than
my body ever thought I could be I killed
all of them the sword god damn it give
it to me how do I build armor maybe I
should build an armor first yeah I'll
get armor I'm not strong enough yet but
I'm strong enough to know my limits then
I got an egg from the chicken a Nico
lied to me now we build a furnace that's
right did I build it or what we can make
Iren we should we make from iron ore and
charcoal what is this then that's just
cold well how do you make charcoal from
lava bucket
what jungle wood now what this is so
complicated or you can use different
things okay okay okay I got it I got it
I got it I got it I got it I'm a genius
I know how to play games for kids mine
I'm gonna be so goddamn strong all right
that's all I got that's right and it's
making it it's making it
it's smelting it's smelting it's
smelting it's working Yatta Yatta Yatta
Iren I did an iron it's no big deal
let's put some more on there oh heck
yeah oh heck yeah we can do trapdoors
Cheers what is that I want to make armor
oh god we need so much dude do I look
like I'm rich or something oh dude we
need way more all right can make the
helmet dude I got a frickin helmet I got
a frickin helmet guys this is epic can
you guys be quiet I'm just gonna farm
around them
god damn it it looks like I'm getting
hungry I have to I'm actually playing
Minecraft guys it's happening
vegetarians please look away for what I
must do
[Applause]
I'm sorry I'm so sorry I need food I
need okay from now on from now on i'm
benjy okay
I'm veggie Bros don't worry I'm vegan
[Music]
I'm lost
fight me that fight minute this guy's
soft okay kill one I killed one
what did I get bone and arrow are you
snake I heard you
[Music]
you can't hang with us you can't hang
with us
go away god damn it they suck I can make
a smithing table what it's all this what
are we doing this nothing apparently
great ok I can make an iron sword that
should be good right then I'll make an
iron pickaxe I got my pickaxe iron baby
big moment he just thought I couldn't do
it hey oh I'm sorry do I have Iren boots
that's goddamn right I had look I'm
freaking pimpin dude yes some more iron
you killed father go away oh god there's
so many dude look at that now who's a
widow B I'm gonna get that kinsella tons
from before I don't care how long it
takes to me I'm gonna have my goddamn
revenge I have so much iron dude I have
so much iron you guys don't understand
oh no no no no no no no it's bad alright
god I gotta I gotta I gotta eat oh god
not like this
[Music]
eat it eat it okay okay okay okay I'm
ready
[Music]
yeah you want some you want some come
get some yeah I know how to play my
grave what blade man crack before dude
we went so far down like bottom of the
earth dude and it's still bright out
nuts dude okay I may have gone a little
sidetrack for like an hour or two I'm
gonna find my way back do I know which
direction to go no no I don't oh I
definitely been here come on right
here's where I was running from the
skeletons if there's water here then
we're golden
oh my god yes
I think I found a half there oh my god
this is where I started I think this was
it this is literally it it was down
there oh all right
let's build a looking house dude we're
gonna build a house
[Music]
[Applause]
we gotta hurry up boys this is getting
dark boys
how do I build a door door
[Music]
perfect just need you guys in tiny
zombie dude it's need one more Lam know
what I say just need it for the bed I
just need it for the bed what the hell
is that what the hell are you doing ah
[Music]
leave me alone I can crazy people in
this game that's right you can't enter
my house leave me alone
yeah that's right my house now I'm gonna
make a bed and you can't sleep with it
yeah that's right my house is awesome
dude you mean there are my god damnit
can you get away ah you're gonna die
you're gonna die
you want some potions I'm gonna sell
your ass okay
now what are you drawing
[Music]
nothing of value all right let's go to
bed
sweet dreams Oh God
okay this is it we're heading out to
reclaim what was ours I think it was
here somewhere
don't worry I'll find it what does that
mean I don't I didn't remember it
because I took away the lava right so
you got old dark and I'm like I don't
remember it being so dark they'd better
be down there or they'd better be ready
I see them whoa yes got him
who's next who's next
oh god there's so many got one oh my god
this is the most intense gameplay yeah
I'm the king
what's in your chair oh look who's
richer you got a collections
you got bread my brain you say no
gunpowder
it's my god pumpkin seeds dude I'm gonna
slay those pumpkin seeds up my butt
where do you come from it's this spawns
them it sad evil huh
oh it's over Oh Bobcat enchanted puck
strings I can make an arrow golden
golden apple apple okay okay okay let's
go let's go let's go let's go let's not
be greedy oh god there's more yeah don't
even scratch me dude
they don't even scratch me brah alright
what happens if you dig deeper than this
we gotta find diamond there we gotta
find diamond bro
[Music]
Oh Oh goddamn dude that's gold not
diamond come on
Oh we hit rock bottom god damn it Jesus
that's Sunday mom it was in the water no
come back come back
Oh what do I drop I have too many
precious items I guess I'll have to drop
the sugar dude I got [ __ ] diamond eat
my ass
are we in done diamond oh yeah oh yeah
oh yeah diamond all right how do I get
out of here I'm just gonna have to dig
out the way my forefathers used to do it
dude I can make it dynamic as right away
oh just I got diamond big ghetto so fast
oh oh oh oh I'm gonna be out in no time
baby
oh yes yeah it's fine back home dude I
dug you like I can shut up cows it's a
horse out there every time there's our
beautiful home my god never been so
happy to see you
we should be able to make an air oh can
we get Bo
TNT we can make TNT
what is that gun I have gunpowder I
cannot stop playing I have a problem how
you doing there buddy
how's it going no now how do I make it
boom how do I make it boom how do i boy
ha ha ha damn it
want to blow up the house ok I think I'm
gonna hand that I preserve there
smashing like if you want more and I see
you guys next time
ah Brooklyn what you never played super
simulator you know it's fun right I'm
not supposed to give my opinion but give
it a try and then you can tell me if
it's good or not not convinced yet ok
I'll cut you a deal
the game is available for free and
that's a great price
[Music]